les fans rozès politologue
bonsoir stéphane rozès merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
est ce que le csa fait de la politique
sur ce coup là stéphane rozès
la force des choses dans un pays comme
le nôtre est en démocratie
au fond dès qu'on prend une décision
des cris noces d'or saints dépendantes
même indépendante prendre une décision
en matière c'est forcément eu aucune
décision politique mais là la question
est
la décision est elle fondée en droit
alors le csa puis sur la loi léotard du
30 septembre
et
constate qu'eric zemmour
comme essayiste et d'aujourd'hui un
acteur du débat politique national
et considère qu'ils doivent des comptes
et au fond comme candidat or il ya quand
même un problème
c'est que eric zemmour n'a pas
formellement
déclarer sa candidature
à la présidentielle d'une part et
d'autre part c'est un éditorialiste et
donc oui c'est braille prendre des
positions politiques me c'est vrai on
est dans une zone un peu grise
net sentiment pendant quelque temps qui
arrime ne savait pas très bien s'il
irait pas
ces derniers jours on a le sentiment que
oui il va y aller sauf que le csm est
une instance indépendante
qui doit juger en droit est le seul
critère c'est et réalisé mourra
technique je suis candidat à la
présidentielle il ne l'a pas fait
stéphane rozès parce qu'il ya eu des
déplacements pour commémorer 2 go le son
éditeur a dit qu'ils eurent près son
contrat car il aurait déclaré vouloir se
lancer dans la présidentielle donc c'est
vrai comme vous dites c'est une zone
grise qui peut être compliqué à gérer
pour le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
bas et le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel si au tout city
et à trancher sur une zone de risma
partir de quels arguments ici ça au fond
de la difficulté
notamment sur le fait qu'eric zemmour a
testé dans une intention de vote
l'ancien patron d'un institut de sondage
que je suis sait bien que on va tester
dès qu'il ya une probabilité
que quelqu'un soit candidat oui mais
formellement il n'est pas candidat et
donc il ya une suspicion et c'est ça qui
est pas bon au fond c'est de faire
passer mort comme victime il ya du coup
une suspicion d'un deux poids deux
mesures en voyez c'est ça qui est très
gênant au fond dans cette décision
puis c est ça effectivement c'était ma
prochaine question ce risque de
victimisation y at il réellement et on
peut se poser la question légitime
aujourd'hui une spécificité zemmour on
sait voilà les sondages dont vous
parliez lui crédité de 7 points alors
qu'il n'est même pas officiellement
candidat on sait qu'il peut gêner aussi
bien à droite mais un peu moins droite
aussi xavier bertrand marine le pen
c'est c'est là que vient la grande
attention qu'on lui porte peut-être plus
qu'un autre
je crois qu'il ya une première
spécificité
c'est qu'eric zemmour est un
éditorialiste c'est un journaliste et
donc son métier basse et d'intervenir
dans les médias et comme il a des succès
des succès d'audience de librairies et
bien du coup il existe ou beige et en
france où le savez un le journalisme
politique et
les éditorialistes
fonds au fond de l'analyse politique
alors pas forcément partisane mais ils
font de l'analyse politique donc la
singularité holmes et moi c'est d'abord
au départ que c'est un fournaise donc il
est dans les médias ça concerne donc
effectivement dans le fonctionnement de
sortie n'est pas d'inégalité ça concerne
le csa mais là en l'occurrence de c'est
sa tranche une zone grise mais c'est pas
drôle c'est cela deux prochaines saisons
une rixe s'est pas l'euro ne cessa de
dire moi je considère ces sacs eric
zemmour est le candidat à la
présidentielle puisqu'il n'a pas dit
qu'il était candidat
par contre comme beaucoup
d'éditorialistes mais plus que d'autres
eric geboers et bien un acteur du débat
politique national c'est vrai mais
l'intéressé parle de censure est ce que
ça peut donner cette impression
justement
aujourd'hui dans un climat de défiance
de la population d'une certaine
population avec le pouvoir
c'est sûr qu'il faut foncer cet énorme
parce que dans cette décision le csa ouf
on fragilise sa légitimité dont
effectivement une perception de
l'opinion à l'égard des médias ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui où on a le sentiment
que les médias dépend à la fois des
intérêts économiques mais aussi dû boire
politique et dans un contexte où ces
derniers mois pour gazon sanitaires pour
des raisons politiques pour des raisons
diverses
il ya dans toute une partie importante
de la population au fond l'idée que les
libertés serait revenu romier et qu'on
essaierait au fond de limiter la
possibilité
d'expression de 10 heures corps de
mécontentement au donc tout ça en plus
se faire effectivement dans un climat où
l'opinion publique peut avoir le
sentiment à mon avis la plupart du temps
à tort mais qu'il y a tout un système
qu'il contrôlerait tout dans la vie
politique
en ce sens je ne comprends pas comme
analystes cette décision du csa merci
beaucoup stéphane rozès que nous avoir
apporté en tout cas votre analyse ce
soir merci à vous et